folks christmas season is upon us as you
can see we've decorated the set
beautifully for christmas
until that liquor money starts coming in
we can't afford christmas decorations
look it's christmas time
uh can we get some christmas decorations
in here next week i'll pay for them
we'll go to cvs
we'll throw some stuff around anyway
as you can see christmas really means a
lot to us but you know my fit one of the
things i love about christmas i'm being
honest here
are those classic christmas movies on tv
like it's a wonderful life
miracle on 34th street i know it's corny
but i just love it every year when those
things roll around
and i gotta say one of my all-time
favorites is a christmas carol
i just love love love love it when that
comes on tv
every year i especially love the part
where scrooge is visited by all the
ghosts
i just think that's so cool i never get
sick of it and i've always thought those
scenes were pretty neat
and that got me thinking that there i
think there are three ghosts in that
movie there has got to be some
other ghosts out there ghosts that
weren't
in the original movie and i thought we
could maybe meet some of them
tonight in a little segment we're going
to call conan's
christmas ghosts wouldn't that be fun
a little rogue
folks for us this is spending a lot of
money so play along all right
i realize this is not all right isn't
this great i got my little
bed here yeah
oh yeah this is great got my little hat
on
guess some ghosts are gonna be coming by
pretty soon
[Music]
who are you i am the ghost of christmas
sweaters
it's uh it's nice to meet you so uh what
do you think of this sweater
it's okay you uh think i could wear it
after christmas
i wouldn't you're probably right thanks
alright bye
[Music]
hello conan wow
who are you i am the christmas ghost
who's afraid of ghosts
so why are you here i'm here to show you
that was amazing
[Applause]
hello conan i am the ghost of christmas
past
come with me finally this is going to be
great this is terrific let's go this is
a real
[Music]
here we are my god that's me
actually that's me this is my past
wait i i thought we were going to my
past why would i do that i don't even
know you
i i just thought hey hey get over
yourself man
oh look there's my puppy hi dubst
you want to see some little league
trophies no i'm getting the hell out of
here yeah
whatever bye
[Music]
so uh who are you i'm the ghost of
christmas shark attacks
why are you here to tell you that
sometimes
on christmas some people decide to go
swimming in the ocean
and although it's very rare it's
happened twice in the last 100 years
shark attacks do happen on christmas
what does that have to do with me oh
um just giving you a heads up man um
actually in case you have any plans to
go swimming in the ocean for christmas
yeah i'm not gonna go swimming oh okay
uh what are you doing
i'm just spending time with my family in
boston nice yeah nice so uh
yeah you're probably not even gonna go
in the ocean at all then huh
no okay right right wow
see you later okay yeah man merry
christmas yeah take care
conan who are you
i am the ghost of a guy who died in the
theater
while watching the movie ghost
that's just terrible that's awful yeah
so uh
how did the movie ever end does uh
demi moore hook up with that bad guy or
is
patrick swayze do something or
you know i i don't it's been such a long
time i don't remember goldberg
no i don't i don't remember no i can't
remember
what about sleepless in seattle you
should go just go
[Music]
hello colin uh who are you
just follow me i'll show you
oh there
wait who are you i'm the ghost of
christmas
who likes to have people watch me while
i work out
what do you think what do i think of
what
these guns they're great i'm gonna head
back
[Applause]
thanks
so who are you i'm the ghost of
christmas recent past
the ghost of christmas recent past yes
come with me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're gonna take a little
break